[Music]
and welcome back to another amazing
episode of the careful boys and today we
have
julia child back in the office oh hello
and today we wanted to talk about some
[ __ ] stories
take it away yeah this was her idea not
our idea oh boys country
she literally was like i have some [ __ ]
stories i want to talk about because
like
about dick and [ __ ] too yeah it's not
just boys yep okay this sausage face and
it wouldn't be jk unless there was a
good [ __ ] story from time to time
people take shits we all take shits okay
everyone takes shits yeah whoa
whoa
personal [ __ ] story before yeah it's
unless you've
done it like
you're not fully jk unless you've done
it yeah i feel like it's been a while
since i've shared a shift yeah so you
got an updated one
so you know as you guys know i'm like uh
i'm having a better work-life balance
and i'm figuring out my new hobbies and
you know i went to go hiking with my
friends
and um on this hike it was like out in
laguna hills please don't find this
thing just please let's find that turd
no don't
find that oh
what was the hiking trail i'll buy it
for 2000
honestly i don't remember but my friend
said that it was like a five mile kind
of trail all right guys so laguna hills
residents in that area five miles julia
fans out there right now that's
as soon as they heard this they're on
their way to laguna hills
[Laughter]
yeah uh so uh yeah we just drove there i
think it was like on
i don't know how relevant this is but i
was like day two on my period and you
know sometimes you just you just figured
that you know cramps are just not like
just cramps you know so it's not a
diarrhea cramp oh i see it's a mystery
yeah and so like we were on the trail
and then like halfway through i just
remember like my body being like yo girl
you gotta take a [ __ ] soon and i'm like
no no no no no these are just cramps
like it's gonna be fine right and so
internal drama yo girl yo girl
you gotta say your body straight
sometimes right the sassy lady honey you
better pull over
you have a blowout
you get cramps in your butthole
no it's just it's just that when you
have it's still abdominal huh yeah yeah
like something to paint this thong down
let's fill this g string
shorts are about to be pants
so we were almost getting to the trail
but i just remember like my body was
like dude you're gonna pass out right
now and i was like oh that's bad yeah
from holding it because i was like
thinking oh because i was just thinking
i was like i'll pass right let me just
fart it no pass
oh fart don't test it walking walking
makes it worse like you have to poop the
longer you walk the faster it comes out
yeah it helps the digestion you realize
that now unless you do handstand water
oh yeah that's true sure so it hit you
in the car or hit you during the hike it
hit me during the hike and there was
like no bath yeah yeah i told my friends
like are you talking like
goosebumps cold sweat yeah yeah yeah
pretty much between the cheeks
how many people were you no how many
gallons
it was it was me and two other people
guys are girls girls okay so you guys
got that security going on a little bit
oh good i said yeah but like guys are
more understanding with that so let's be
honest at the time though i didn't tell
them i was on my period and i didn't
tell them my house was a stomachache
because i was like oh it will pass like
usually you just pass it so they were
judging you no they were not judging me
they were great friends okay but then
like we we almost got to the top but
like i couldn't do it anymore because i
think every time i go up the hill like
it just used a lot of i don't know like
body strength there's a lot of opposing
forces yeah what's the change of
pressure in elevation right your
butthole's getting looser so then
they're like chemistry this is basically
sucking it out of your ass every 300
feet your [ __ ] gets like one diameter
a little bit bigger that's true
yeah that's how you measure it but pinky
nail yeah
they were they were very understanding
and they're like oh yeah yeah we'll turn
around because i was like dude i'm gonna
i'm gonna [ __ ] die and so like as we
were walking back i was like okay cool i
think i'm okay and then at one point i
was like no guys i gotta take a [ __ ] cuz
like i was like literally on the floor
in like fetal position i was like guys i
gotta go
wait you went into the little pooper
scooper tutti pootie whatever position
to like
does that make you come out where'd you
go i was walking and then i literally
just like went down like this just to
take a break on the trail just because
it was hurting so bad [ __ ] harder when
you squat
body squatting i didn't realize this and
so after a while i was like i gotta
[ __ ] go and so i went over to the
bushes okay i thought you were trail
[ __ ] for a second yeah
trail [ __ ] i was scared i thought she
farted and [ __ ] in her pants yeah i
almost did
thank god dude good thing dude if i had
kept going and walking like i probably
would have but then i went over into
like the bushes but i couldn't go far
enough
into it so like you could kind of see me
but if i duck you wouldn't be able to
walk wow and like literally my friends
were like don't worry we got you and i
was like what is that even supposed to
so they pull out their cell phones no
they're on lookout yeah they're just
look out for you they're on lookout and
then i guess there's like a big tour
group that was oh no no
[ __ ] under these circumstances when i
feel like there's a tour go coming by
what if what if they end up being
mainland chinese you're like oh thank
god
they're all pooping too okay there's a
bathroom right here behind the bus
there's a lady going right now yeah
yeah literally so then
guys oh time to [ __ ] it felt so weird
because i was like what is the protocol
for shooting out in nature you never did
it before no this is my first time no
one's one of the best things in the
world what did your wife wear virgin
[ __ ] experience didn't obama do that on
like with guy bear grylls well yeah
obama and bear grylls was out there
[ __ ] all over their girls drank
obama's piss too yeah he did that what
the [ __ ] what what did you wipe with a
sock or you didn't even wipe um
disgusting person i put a pad there was
a pad we had pads
just one pad we there we had a few
that's all you need sometimes was it
solid or was it like nah man it was
[ __ ] runny i just remember because i
was like oh i don't know even how to
like position myself because i was like
how did i do i do this like i don't know
how
to do it
is it from taco bell
no no
could have been del taco i don't know i
don't remember what i ate so it was like
indigestion kind of stuff going on i
don't know was it uh loud yeah does it
go flat
yeah how many pushes it just it just
came out
also it's just like
yeah
you know what the whole opens up dude
have you ever had diarrhea so [ __ ]
bad that it's all water
yeah like it just squeezed like wow easy
cleanup though if you haven't had have
you ever had did you did you afterward
it's like you're out of the woods you
know what i mean it's like oh my god did
you just hug your [ __ ] friends start
crying
fold your knees
we're so proud of you there was there
was no there was a moment but nothing of
like was it like splashing when it like
hit the ground instead there's like a
couple like residue like drops on your
socks and stuff oh no no no it just like
came out in one pile and it just did you
make like a like a nickelodeon show
there was no time and i didn't have a
shovel and then but luckily there was
like a pile of twigs like dry twigs
conveniently and i just decorate oh
you're one of those people that takes
you on the floor and they're like
nothing happened
i didn't know what else to do it takes a
squirrel's home and then wow
put a bird's nest the bird comes back
and goes
[ __ ] vomits on its own kids and [ __ ]
you know what they do usually
no that's maybe too real all right
i uh recently in hawaii i haven't [ __ ]
outside in a long time but uh recently
in hawaii we all have a story i love
this yeah i love jake yeah no i just
love that you're just yeah this is this
was just a few a few uh a few months ago
so me gio and taiko went to hawaii and
then we went to this like little cove
place
and um oh cool like there's like turtles
in this cone so i'm like i'm gonna climb
like on the rocks all the way to the end
because you're not like sometimes out of
this cove then you can see the edge of
the ocean and it looks [ __ ] sick so i
go there with my fins and my snorkel and
then we just had zippies and then like i
was like oh [ __ ] i think i feel
something as i was walking towards
towards it you know and i was like
maybe i should kind of wait around a bit
because it's one of those things where
like the waves are kind of strong
so it's one of those like you can't just
[ __ ] like drive by [ __ ] because if
you like are in the water and you [ __ ]
the wave will probably blast the [ __ ]
back at your face
like it was [ __ ] and then crash back on
i was like this is not uh like very
smooth water
and then out and i was like okay [ __ ]
because because and also since it looks
so rapid it's one of those where like
once you jump in the water and if you
put your snorkel mask on and your fins
and all that stuff it's going to take a
minute to get everything on it's not
like just the swimming pool you know so
i'm like this is kind of risking your
life to take a [ __ ] in the ocean is what
it sounds like yeah sounds like there's
a riptide so like this is kind of rough
but i also really want to jump in the
water and then it really hit me and i'm
like oh [ __ ] so i climbed over the rocks
to the other side where uh i would be
able to have i would be able to be the
first person to have visibility if
someone came in what would you tell them
wait
don't come
i'm sorry i'm [ __ ] bro i don't know
oh the bra yeah so i sat there and then
i pulled my my trunks down i just
[ __ ] spread my butt cheeks we don't
have tissue paper or whatever right
something i just want things to come out
like you manually added the spreading of
the butt cheese
so that so that because you know when
you like eat something at a fine dining
restaurant
when you have smears of the beef
wellington you go like this
right but if you can eat it like
that he won't have to watch true i'm
sorry can you show me again i didn't get
i don't think we have to spread our
cheeks when we squat spreading full
spread i was spreading it so i don't i
don't have to dab that makes sense it's
like he's presenting it yeah
bart's got such a thick nice ass i guess
oh yeah that he's really got a point
poop on his butt cheeks all the time
all the time so i just i [ __ ] still hot
and then i uh when i jumped in the water
then i made sure i did the hawaiian
bidet and then everything was good the
hawaii wait but damn did you [ __ ] off
the side of the cliff cliff no it's on
the cliff it's on the cliff well you
[ __ ] on the cliff that's even worse
someone's gonna see it if they go around
if they if they're like exploring
we all know we all know what joe would
do we all know what joe would do he'd
take his [ __ ] in the ocean and then he'd
be like oh someone took a [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
oh
there's only three other people there
those guys were too crazy that day
he's disgusting
who would do that who would take a [ __ ]
oh he took a big [ __ ] in the ocean
someone shattered the sea anemone look
no he cried inside it went like this too
[ __ ] see that'd be caught up this is
definitely a human shed
have you guys ever [ __ ] inside the water
like while you're in the pool like
in hawaii i bet it's nice how do you do
that how do you let a log go
in the ocean you literally just spread
your butt cheeks you [ __ ] and then
immediately i try to [ __ ] kick it
because i don't want the [ __ ] to come
out wait did you see the [ __ ] like
all over the ground so you're doing one
of the egg beaters because like does it
stay solid or to be honest uh i think i
[ __ ]
and then i didn't look and i think i
started a dolphin kitchen
that thing was watching there's been a
time where anyone was swimming towards
you and you knew that there was
purposely slam away from everyone uh and
then i was like oh [ __ ]
i've never seen this [ __ ] in the ocean i
always thought that would be a terrible
idea i saw a video but it was a natural
dude no but i thought it would smear all
over your body and like break apart and
you'll be like [ __ ] trying to get
away from the [ __ ]
if it's not through the ocean are you
like afterwards like wiping your ass
with your hand yeah the hawaiian but
then i [ __ ] straight up go like this
i make sure everything is good and nice
and clean and then i [ __ ] go like
that too and then i check to see if
there's anything with the fingernails
and then yeah i gotta clean your
fingernails yeah i get it
but it's salt water baby
i saw a video years ago where a man
takes a [ __ ] in the ocean solid [ __ ] and
fish just start attacking
i'm not kidding
it was like in the coral wreath area oh
so you're actually feeding the ecosystem
out there yeah it's just like that's
right it's [ __ ] up
it's pretty gross all the fish die
immediately afterwards but all the coral
reefs are dying anyway so yeah exactly i
will say uh when i was a kid i went to
this like kind of more uh poor area in
vietnam
and uh this is a buddhist temple area
and uh they have like an outhouse that
is like just it's literally built and
stands right over a little pond there's
giant catfish in there and then you know
like it's not like [ __ ] flushable
toilets it's just a [ __ ] hole and you
squat
and i'm a kid so i'm like trying to put
the two and two together i'm like
where does the poop go so my mom was
like goes in the water i was like
that's it that's just poop bar it's like
all the fish eat it something oh [ __ ]
okay so it's like it's like a toilet
seat that's outside and it just drops
literally there's there's space so like
i had to try it so i [ __ ] took a [ __ ]
there into it
that would suck that's okay well i took
a [ __ ] and literally just
you just see the water start going crazy
and just giant catfish or just eating
[ __ ] yeah and then they eat the fish
after right circle of life yeah we did
eat the catfish whoa
best sushi ever had in your life i bet
it wasn't sushi but great fish yes but
doesn't catfish already taste like [ __ ]
though uh i love it aren't they bottom
feeders though yeah yeah they kind of
have a shitty flavor to it like no lie
like it yeah
they're delicious when you eat them in
vietnamese we're not saying they're not
delicious
they don't know but i'm not saying i
don't like [ __ ] there's a hand yeah
there is
of cocka in that fish meat what do you
say about my people all right it's not
just
yourself dude southern people love
catfish bro i got chocolate you want to
talk about disney seed tokyo japan or
whatever that's what i ate i know that's
talking about the pastrami sandwich
but they don't taste like cocka catfish
sandwich
you know what i mean which one i think
catfish has a hint of cocka flavor to it
i've never tasted it
i honestly don't eat cocka a lot so i
don't really know like what's your frame
of reference
have you had intestines
cause i eat stinky tofu and it doesn't
taste anything like it there you go but
have you had have you had intestine
to me yeah but when it's like cut up
intestine tastes like coffee yeah it
tastes a little bit like cocka well it
should
i got i got a wild theory it should
i think that's real yeah and tilapia to
me smell tastes like swamp tilapia
there's a little bit of swamp to it i
don't get no swamps if it's like farmed
right what about why
taste anything to you no why is sweet
what about what about just [ __ ] guys
what a [ __ ]
tastes like chocolate
really no one's tasted that wait that
was off the record
there it is
and there it is
[Applause]
he ended the video with a little liner
and then he's like yeah i think i just
[ __ ] finished that one
so back to shit's stories
was that it that was it i really liked
that it was all girls around yeah oh
yeah first of all that's pretty tight
that's really brave girls are i mean by
the way i i mean living with women over
the many years i have i've realized that
they're just as disgusting as dudes like
no
i know but you just don't think that
growing up like growing up when you're
looking at chicks and movies and [ __ ]
you're just like man chicks are like
[ __ ] oh my god angels we got to clean
it up around them i always feel like
there's a difference too when uh the
first time you see a like the girls
bathroom
it's [ __ ] disgusting yeah like it's
like the guy's bathroom's gross but
that's also because guys are kind of
open with how they're [ __ ] [ __ ] up in
the bathroom it's kind of funny but then
i always feel like girls don't admit
when they're like like you you go to a
girl's bathroom should be [ __ ] on the
ground but no one's fessing up yeah but
then guys are like yo that was me bro
yeah yeah
dude i showed you around dude hey i left
a welcome mat
and worry about it
i gotta say though a lot of uh i have
been in a number of girls restrooms
and they are much cleaner you ever you
ever go i agree one of those restroom
situations at a restaurant and then like
the guy's restroom is just [ __ ]
locked and you're like [ __ ] i have to
pee right now yeah yeah if it's a nice
place
he's like he works there he's like you
just use women's you go to the women's
and it's [ __ ] glorious nice yeah
they've got a fake little plant in there
that's some [ __ ] potpourri and [ __ ]
like that they have like seating yeah
you know what that's dripping down to
put a whole [ __ ] thing because it's
like wait a minute nobody pees like that
there's chicks at the urinals like that
you gotta go to a place where they're
like where men and women have to all
fend for themselves and it's not
convenient the girls bathroom's gonna be
pretty [ __ ] gross you gonna like you
go to like a stadium when like the game
is on and the women's line is [ __ ]
long guarantee that
you know what they don't have julia do
you have you ever been in a girl's
bathroom and it says
they wrote this if you're reading this
you're a [ __ ]
have you ever seen that girls yeah
that's true have you ever no what kind
of graffiti is i've seen that in so many
[ __ ] guys bathrooms dude
and i'm like damn it it's like that i
don't know
because i'm just reading i'm like oh you
didn't give me this time god that is
because
they do write that word
is it the same guy there's just [ __ ]
poems from crackheads what kind of hate
speech is there in the world
it's just like you're beautiful in
everything
yeah
[ __ ] yeah you don't see an occasional
swastika or something like that when
you're sitting down a poop
okay yeah none of that yeah
is always out there drawings there's
like numbers but like never any [ __ ] you
[ __ ] yeah
they don't like draw like vaginas in
there because we got a bunch of penises
on ours
i was reading online though if you read
it backwards so it's like it says if
you're reading this you're a [ __ ] if
you read it backwards you're straight as
[ __ ]
oh
cause you unread it yeah yeah yeah
that's how you come back that's how you
beat it i'll try that next time because
my current status is not so good right
now
i tried it for my overkill from
i'm quite the gay man
yeah i don't know why our bathrooms
always have to look like you know some
type of crime scene was there you know
like it's like it's like a scene from
saw or like you walk into like if you go
to a [ __ ] gas station right it's like
all nice it's cute it has like bubble
gum and [ __ ] and when you walk into the
bathroom it looks like somebody's going
to come in there and try to [ __ ] me yeah
i've been into a gas station bathroom
where there's a whole roll of paper
towel just in the middle
huh the toilet like the whole roll of it
i'm like what's that's [ __ ] funny how
did it get there what is this art piece
what kind of statement is this that's a
classic yeah it's like an archaeological
dig it's like what was this culture
doing
and like what was there you know what
was this ritual what was the motivation
i'm very curious
it's like in height in eighth grade
someone had left their shoes right next
to the toilet for some reason and for
like two days straight everyone would
just piss in them
and then the shoe was like so full yeah
you gotta fill it up nobody wanted to
admit it was their shoes because it's so
embarrassing
except for a kid with no shoes on one
time i got i got [ __ ] boys are
ruthless i don't know i don't know why i
was doing this it was freshman year of
high school and for some [ __ ] reason
i thought i might have said this i
thought it'd be funny to just keep
pissing in the tank of the toilet
so that's that gabriel i would take the
top off the toilet i just pissed it
every day so it's just when the next guy
flushes it's just more
that's different that's why this that's
why this [ __ ] head thinks that the
girl's bathroom is just as bad as the
guys because he's probably just in there
doing it
he's [ __ ] up he's [ __ ] up yo
ryan's wild ryan's [ __ ] wild i told
you you know i like it it wasn't like i
was telling anyone i was doing it i just
thought it was like personal humor i was
like that's pretty funny and then one
time i think a guy saw me through the
little crack in the [ __ ] door he saw
me doing it and then he and then i heard
him go outside and like ask a teacher if
you pee in the tank does it come out
when you flush and i was like oh you
[ __ ] saw me a little brat dude
[ __ ] rapping
for another three hours hoping for the
window to pass he just he just asked the
teacher ladies and gentlemen yeah do you
guys remember in careful boys in careful
boys group chat when ryan said if you
guys want to find out who somebody is i
got you [ __ ] covered i know i know i
know hackers and then i'm like whatever
and then no we're like yo ryan's [ __ ]
wild
because people don't know that you know
fiverr where you like commission art
stuff you can commission like private
investigator people from all around the
world to just identify like it'll
literally say just write the word
identify in fiverr you'll get a long
list of people that go i can identify
anyone online read between the lines
right now though don't [ __ ] ryan's
wild don't [ __ ] the guy
it's like ten bucks don't [ __ ] with him
it's like ten bucks and there's people
from like countries where the laws are
different so they're not never gonna get
caught and they'll just go okay here's
what came back it's this person like is
that familiar but to be fair you they
won't do it unless you justify
some reason why them like harassing you
makes you in fear of your life or
something you have to like tell them
like oh this person online is harassing
me talking [ __ ] or whatever says he says
i'm a [ __ ] booby pants i'm not a
boobyman yeah and then they'll do it and
then they'll just delete their account
right after so they can't be like traced
wow that crazy that's legit
yeah try it out sit up straight around
ryan like this hello sir yeah paul ryan
sir ryan sir yes sir i will be at your
birthday party you shirt
you